and we are with the Women's Champion
Naza you put kids he playing the
fantastic chest throughout the entire
event a deserving champion first of all
congratulations thank you how does it
feel after all the hard work all the
effort eleven days all the gym workouts
what does it feel like right now to be
the champion of the country I'm still
shaky I cannot believe this happened
sorry this is gonna be very emotional
interview probably I feel like I'm in a
dream because coming to this game I knew
that chances of me winning with black
and tired of losing was extremely small
and then I got a good position I
probably was winning somewhere before
and I missed it probably somewhere and
then I look at Adams game and she
resigns and I almost freaked out us like
I just blew my game probably and then I
had to win it again calm down and win it
again
this is all just you had to beat arena
crushes a seven-time champion with the
black pieces that's a totally tall order
on any day you'd be happy to draw Trump
and yet you started playing these moves
94 95 f5 what were you feeling when you
were making these moves on the board
well going to the game I just wanted to
go all in and that was not happy with
the opening because I knew that such a
positional position and she was better
and I was pretty disappointing and then
as soon as I got the chance to
complicate position I didn't even think
about it I just went for it
she played that for actually giving you
that chance then you played b5 yes right
away did you work out all these time no
intuition there were moments when you
could have won yes that's some night
discoveries in the position you did you
see those where you're looking at the
moment you were afraid to go for them
because it might have been a mistake
yeah I was calculating 93 I probably
spent like 20 minutes instead of night
eastery I just couldn't calculate that
she had so many moves Bishop takes d5
and on King f8 I think she definitely
had some conversation so I had to go
King h8 and if she manages to bring her
rook or queen on hfl and checkmate it so
I didn't want to risk it because I
thought after Knight is three
still had good winning chances so I felt
more safe planet yeah 93 was definitely
winning in 1987 was the best page 7 yeah
we 870 allowing g6 King 86 which was
super sharp but even in the next move
you're at night you know at 93 twice she
gave it to you again
even here 93 was also not this one night
d3 thanks I was happened to be winning
if she takes just play Knight takes on
g2 and you're discovering on her oh I
felt after Queen after my night was
stuck I just have 90 stranger Knight
comes back out on e3 so blind spots
amateur your still dominates right
except the one moment she she could have
maybe equalized but you started playing
very positioning you control the game
like you said did you worry at the end
that she had built a fortress so did you
feel like you were gonna bake so after
she took on c5 and she was left with the
bishop on a5 I felt I felt very good I
was like there's no way I'm not gonna
win this and then we went to that
endgame here I think I made too many
unnecessary moves but still I know that
the endgame is winning even if I just
exchanged one rope that and game is
waning so no I was sure that I was gonna
win I was just afraid to maybe plant or
something then we saw when you won the
game how you reacted and we have it on
screen right now and also here it is
your win you're surprised at winning and
also a beautiful moment there with with
your husband what do they mean to be a
champion with your husband and
attendants I think he's the only one who
believed this outcome could happen today
and I don't know I have to thank him
because he's the one who supports me the
most and he's the one who told me to
deliver myself that everything still
could go my way today yes and we saw him
in Paris you try to gather yourself and
realize that you are indeed the champion
of these here United States and here it
is a special moment with your husband
how hard did you guys work and think
about this event so that you could you
could possibly win it after coming in
second place next year
I mean last year um so actually I since
last championship I haven't played just
much but this last couple months I was
seriously preparing for this tournament
and my husband was helpful he was
supporting me as much as he could in any
way he could and we knew coming in that
this was going to be my big event so I
wanted to do my best and actually a
couple days ago when I made a quick draw
against Urbina and set the house
Calandra the queen against that ever I
was like okay Lucky's on tatev side
there's no way I'm gonna win this and I
actually got quite sad and again my
husband was the only one who told me
that everything could still go my way I
have to say it though I do feel terrible
for my friend tatev I think she also
played really well and deserved to win
this tournament especially because she
was so close so many times this is just
my second time and I really feel bad for
her you did not lose a single game last
year you did not lose a single game this
year you played the wonderful chest your
final thoughts and what it means to be
the US Women's Champion I said I really
still cannot believe this has happened I
have to excuse me game just under 10
minutes ago it's unbelievable i mean i'm
i actually feel proud of myself that I
finished the tournament without losing a
game and it's just like my dream to win
a championship
congratulations you're deserving winner
fantastic chest we're waiting to see you
get the Grandmaster title because you
play like a grandmaster thank you for
his tournament congratulations on being
the champion now see for kids II the
champion of the women's champion of the
United States of America a fantastic
result for her and completely
well-deserved our deepest
congratulations indeed Nyjah well